outra coisa que eu tenho ódio é quando
alguém me oferece uma coisa só uma vez
porque se você me oferece Eu nego por
educação não é porque eu não quero não
só prô oferecer de novo a pessoa fala
assim PR mim é um pedaço dessa caixa de
F digo não tô de boa acabei de almoçar
ah tá bom e eu fico eu tava com um fome
ningu só por educação Queria um pedaço
dessa caixa de
fósforo agora é ruim também quando você
tá na posição contrária quando você
oferece por educação e aí você espera
que a pessoa vai dizer Não por educação
também é pedaço cacha F par o querol
tava morrendo de fome tu fica filha da
aceitou engraçado quando é ele ele
não me oferece Não essa desgraça olha
comer todinho vai comer todinho com meu
mano na metade hum engraçado né que eu
falei que eu dei do primeiro de no
segundo eu fiz a mesma coisa é uma
hipocrisia né impacta seu implanta deixa
ser implanta